[Music]
i wrote a song
with lyrics made from imagenet class
labels
and then i used openai's clip model
together with a big gan and a back
propagation procedure
to generate a music video that fits the
lyrics of the song
the song is performed on a live looper
and the lyrics mean
absolutely nothing i hope you
think this is as cool as i do
enjoy
[Music]
girl and my sleeping bag
all dressed up in my shower cap
soon i'll be on a larger screen
with my head in a guillotine
my hair smells like an old dish track my
face looks like a used or not my spine
is like a horizontal bar
[Music]
these are just some things you'll find
on image now
a thousand cuts of joy but mostly things
to bet
be my weasel
[Music]
watch out for the king snake the vine
snake
the green snake and don't forget the
night snake
the sea snake and the pug
find the big
and here i sit in my rocking chair
looking for my purple hair
what's inside wooden chest
maybe it is my bulletproof vest
i hear a border collie cry bernie's
mountain dog goes by and
all the while two hummingbirds stay near
those are just some things you'll find
on imagenet
a thousand cuts of joy but mostly things
to pat
be my weasel
[Music]
watch out for the king snake the vine
snake
the green snake and don't forget the
knights make
the sea snake and the bug
find a big
[Music]
[Laughter]
find an ego catch a
bring them home
so how was this all made see if you want
ai to generate you images
you have to have a model that learned
from a data set
in our case this is a generative
adversarial model
or again gans are amazingly good at
producing high quality
images the cool thing about again is
that what you need to do
is you need to sample a point in what's
called the latent space
and then you'll get out a picture in
picture space
now if you have two points in litten
space you can also go
from one to the other in a stepwise
fashion we call that
interpolation or traversal if you
sequence those pictures
one after another it gives you a video
of
morphing one picture into the other we
came up with a picture
for each line of lyric and then we
simply traverse the latent space
in sync with the music in order to
produce this video but
how did we even get the initial pictures
and how did we make them
fit the text that's where openai's clip
model comes in so clip is a model that
takes a piece of text
and a picture and it will give you a
number telling you
how well the two fit together or not
now that in itself will not be useful
but the useful part comes when you
realize
that the picture part of the pipeline is
fully differentiable that means we can
back propagate the error signal
all the way to the image space so what
we do
in practice is we take a clip and we put
a piece of text in our case
one line of lyrics for the picture we
don't just put a picture
we actually put the output of a gan in
our case we use
big gan that has been trained on a
variety of images
and can produce amazing images by itself
we take the
output of big gan and feed it into the
input of
clip and now that we have all of this we
back propagate the error that clip tells
us through
the image part of clip through the
gan into the latent space of the game
so in essence we start off with a random
picture that might not fit the text at
all
but then through back propagation over
many hundreds of steps
we find a point in the input space of
the gan
that more and more and more makes the
clip model
happy now this doesn't always give you
very realistic images
however it usually gives you pretty cool
images
like this one is the spine being a
horizontal bar
it's not exactly horizontal but still
very very cool
and this here is the face being a used
doormat
i think this is amazing so we feed each
line of lyrics through this system
get out a point in the latent space that
gives us a picture
that is fitting to that line of lyrics
and then with all these points in the
latent space all we need to do is
traverse them in order
synchronized up with the music and we
have ourselves a music video
for the song itself i took imagenet
lyrics and
made them into a song text this isn't
because
i'm superbly musically talented or
anything
but usually youtube and music copyright
aren't best friends i just wanted to
avoid all of that stuff and so i came up
with my own song
so the lyrics mean absolutely nothing
there's no hidden meaning
i struggled already enough to actually
find some rhymes
and yeah that's what came out the song
is played in a
loop fashion so all the songs are
produced by
me in some form or another my gear
is i use a boss ve2
as a voice processor for harmonies
though i only use it at the very end in
this song i use a boss rc 500
for looping
that's pretty new to me and i still have
my troubles with it
and the boss octave oc5 pedal
[Music]
in order to simulate a bass with my
guitar
my guitar is a little martin electro
acoustic guitar
it sounds pretty good honestly
the flaw in this setup is probably the
microphone i used to record this with
as it is an ipad microphone and i didn't
have anything else
i guess i could have used this one
yeah i was pretty stupid for not
thinking of that i can't whistle anymore
and yes i did buy this combo after i saw
ed sheeran perform live
absolutely amazing so usually i'm pretty
comfortable
playing in front of people i have
terrible stage fright but
i do overcome it pretty quickly cameras
is a different thing as soon as the
camera's rolling
like my brain just turns off so this
was certainly my 20th attempt or so at
recording this song
and not even now i have it down so
forgive a little bit
of cracks in voices and my whistling
was a bit tired at this point i hope you
still enjoy it
i'm gonna let the play the song one more
time with a different generation
of a music video
[Music]
curling in my sleeping bag
all dressed up in my shower cap
soon i'll be on a larger screen
with my head in a guillotine
my hair smells like an old dish track my
face looks like a used or matte my spine
is like a horizontal bar
these are just some things you'll find
on imagenet
a thousand cuts of joy but mostly things
to bet
be my weasel
[Music]
watch out for the king snake the vine
snake
the green snake and don't forget the
night snake
the sea snake and the pug
find the beagle catch us
[Music]
and here i sit in my rocking chair
looking for my purple hair
what's inside the wooden chest
maybe it is my bulletproof vest
i hear a border collie cry bernie's
mountain dog
goes by and all the while two
hummingbirds stay near
[Music]
those are just some things you'll find
on imagenet
a thousand cuts of joy but mostly things
to pet
[Music]
bring them home to my whiskey jar
watch out for the king snake the vine
snake
the green snake and don't forget the
night snake
the sea snake and the bug
find a
[Music]
be my weasel
find an ego catch a
bring them home
[Music]
be my weasel
thank you so much for watching uh of
course this is not
all my work it's built upon the work of
many great people and i'll link to
as much as i can in the description of
the video so
please check this out a lot of people
have worked
very hard and i'm simply building on top
of them
and they're the same people are actually
pushing the state of the art
of what's possible uh with the clip
model
to an entirely new level that you
wouldn't believe how cool this is
so check it out i've also linked my code
that i've used to produce the music
video you can produce
your own if you want to or play around
with it
special thanks to jr for helping me with
the code
to lance for editing and to you for
watching
a thousand cuts of joy but mostly things
to pat
be my weasel